[Music]
a little bit of work man that don't
scare us i get up i go hard like i'm
george harris make plays break lanes
push way
[Music]
all right my man let's check out some of
your amazing work inside the octagon
we're kicking off what's this first
fight this is paul craig paul craig
tough customer big customer
yeah man
this one was in glasgow i
yeah it was in glasgow and man before i
walked out to this fight
first off like
when we had first faced off he was just
giving me this like energy like just
kind of disrespectful and it pissed me
off a bit okay so i just like i did what
i do and i i balled it all up and then
uh when i was walking out you know this
is in his home you know what i mean his
whole country so obviously everybody's
gonna stop
you know he comes out with braveheart
you know paint on his face and stuff so
um yeah nobody in that arena that night
i felt like wanted me to win i heard
some of the worst things from the from
the crowd
it was crazy man so like i was in full
on like killer be killed mode right yeah
there's wasn't a lot of cleal um reebok
fight kits in the crowd no
no
but i was i was locked in i was
definitely locked you're ready to go for
this one and sometimes it's weird when
you fight on another fighter's home turf
you can either be overwhelming you know
what i'm saying and like it makes the
moment even more intense or you can
channel that kind of negative energy and
use it as a positive exactly
so you clearly changed it challenge it
as a positive let's hit it mike
yeah he's
yellow shorts uh in honor of anderson
silva oh i love it yeah those are the
brazilian face there yeah
what are you thinking there i'm gonna
destroy you
i'm gonna wreck this dude yeah
yeah and he's a tough customer i would
assume he'd be a favorite coming into
the fight hometown too yeah so a lot of
this fight like i felt like you know he
was definitely probably going to try to
take me down because he has a better you
know phenomenal
yeah really really good so i knew it was
going to come
there there becomes a point in the fight
where like i just start kind of taunting
him a bit because i knew that the
takedown was going to come and and you
can just tell the hand speed and you're
clearly more comfortable on the feet
yeah you're pretty you're pretty
relaxing i guess you know you just yeah
you're swinging there very relaxed
and you know like obviously his game
plans to get you down and go for the
choke and he's pretty good at that oh
yeah he is
yeah they seem super relaxing although
there were so many people in the crowd
and like screaming while we were walking
out like while we were in there it was
pretty silent like i could hear a lot of
the stuff his coaches were telling
really yeah
so yeah it's weird with some of that
stuff especially international outside
the us the us just never gets quiet
unless it's a boring fight but during
the main event it's chaos
but in other countries they kind of
it's almost like they're a little more
educated on it and they kind of calm
down they respect the sport and really
tune in and they watch the technique and
stuff like that yeah definitely
yeah he's a big dude too yeah was he
bigger than you expected yeah tall guy
um you know he had a pretty big frame
and i think this was
i was pretty i think i was walking
around at like 218 for this camp so i
was like walking around a bit light oh a
bit light what do you usually walk
around at uh lately it's been like 2 30.
oh damn yeah okay yeah
2 30 but that makes sense 2 30 kept the
205 it's pretty
it's not like out of
nowhere like crazy out of the no i've
gotten up to like 250 before like my
heaviest again like after the weight
loss but
once i start
climbing up into the 240s i know that
like i'm off track yeah time to chill
out yeah so yeah there's just a lot of
the fight i was kind of just
i knew you're patient yeah patient
because i knew that just like as soon as
he wanted yeah see i'm like
um because i knew he wasn't necessarily
going to strike and he was going to go
for the takedown and so
that's just not where i wanted this
fight especially because i felt like a
bit disrespected sure you know so i
wanted it to be something where you know
he engaged in striking a little bit more
poor poor paul craig though man it's
your hometown they give you this killer
who's excellent at stand up you know and
he has to pray to god to get you down
that's the nature of the beast you're
really taunting him yeah yeah like
you're just trying to open up you know
in a way
like without trying to
like try too hard i was thinking i was
really thinking a lot about anderson
that's why i like i i had a little bit
more like calmness that landed there
yeah even like i kind of shook my head
at him because this this fight was a bit
personal to me you know like because you
felt disrespected yeah just like we're
at a minute 55 in the first round you're
kind of starting to get your range there
too he's on the end of your on your
hands now yeah exactly so now that i've
landed a punch i know i'm starting to
know like
yeah my range my distance
and i actually think yeah it's only this
first round
yes oh there's a there is a pretty cool
uh
kick
uh body kick
let's see it should be yeah he's not
offering so much or he's just kind of
waiting for you to commit but you just
kind of
again you're talking about it
it has to be tough for him too yeah
you're also a tough guy to game plan for
oof that left hook landed oh yeah you're
really feeling it now you felt super
disrespected yeah well i wanted him to
like engage in you know in a brawl with
me i was like
you know what i
let's let's go like my hands are down
oh uppercut landed yeah here's a kick
boom see
so like it just sometimes it becomes a
natural it's an instinct in a way
yeah it's just who you are you know
coming up in the in that van der ley gym
yeah
yeah i mean he is completely out classed
on the feet
you've landed three really good shots
and just your speed the technique
it's a tough puzzle for him to
to figure out you can tell especially
the way he's backing up his hands high
like that
and what's interesting is he's no punk
either you know it's not like he's like
this
you know just basic dude he's he's a
tough customer to beat man yeah and
that's that's one thing is like that's
kind of how i felt it was like he looked
at me like i was you know what i mean
yeah i like i was like no i'm not yeah
like see he's kind of open up here
though he's a guy i can't just stand
back and get beat up and this is what
actually helps you out yeah
point
was that short kind of shovel upper hook
a little bit left uppercut yeah look how
mad you are
yeah yeah oh wow
so like not daddy likes daddy likes
sometimes you got to do that sometimes
you know like it's not something that i
like necessarily i'm like
no but like for for the sake of just how
i felt and i felt like he made it
personal there was just some things for
me after knocking him out like after
finishing like that i was like okay i
need to do something yeah that was well
deserved yeah you know what i mean like
now i'm like it's not like i'm like what
like internally actually my thoughts
were like all right it's over yes yeah
i'm saying it's done it doesn't have to
and then after what we talked you know
the whole entire like the hotel was
packed all like all the guys bought me
beers they're like
you know so like it actually all turned
around for me and i was able to shut
that door there and like now if i see
paul craig like there's no no this
shouldn't be yeah we should be like you
know he's like one fair and square yeah
it's not like yeah it's not like you
cheated yourself so it's kind of one of
those things where like yeah i just kind
of had boom yeah that shovel uppercut
really landed but you know just it's all
obviously all in hindsight but just
looking at that it's like this is just a
matter of time you watch that fight
you're landing whenever you wanted you
know yeah that's a good fight though
that was a good win huh yeah i felt good
very brazilian attire there out of you
yeah
a tribute to anderson silva let's take a
little break from chatting with my
brother from a completely different
mother khalil roundtree and going over
all his amazing fights we're having some
fun but before we get back to the
program
a lot of y'all can't sleep man i don't
know what's going on you know growing up
as a kid we had terrible mattresses
maybe the show's put you to sleep you
need a comfy mattress you need something
man but what you need and what i have in
my house i can't get rid of my in-laws i
can't get rid of my family everybody
wants to stay at my house i thought they
just thought i was cool nope
it's the helix mattress man and helix
sleep has a quiz that takes just two
minutes to complete and it matches your
body type and sleep preference to the
perfect mattress just for your thick ass
that's right if you like mattresses
really soft firm you sleep on your side
your back your stomach you sleep hot you
sleep cold whatever it is helix got you
covered with your very own custom
mattress you don't need to take my word
for it helix was awarded the number one
best overall mattress of 2019 and 2020
by gq and wired magazine again i have
them in every
guest room in my crib i can't get rid of
people it's like a hostel up in that bad
boy and i again i thought it's because i
was cool with my girls cooking nope it's
just my helix sleep mattresses i can't
get rid of people
so if that sounds like something you're
into just go to helixsleep.com
take their two minutes sleep quiz they
will match you with your customized
mattress that will give you your best
sleep ever they have a 10 year warranty
you get to try it out for risk free 100
nights and even pick it up but you're
going to love it so don't worry about
that helix sleep is offering up to 200
off all mattress orders and free pillows
for the viewers and listeners of this
show at helixsleep.com
that's
helixsleep.com for up to 200 off now
let's get back to the
if anybody knows anything about k1
kickboxing and just the legendary
work of uh sake you know that this guy
he had a lot of hype on him coming in
too you know
yeah and especially you know you pride
yourself on uh there's kenny johnson i
love that game yeah you pride yourself
on being a striker
which you know in the ufc you're
definitely a well-known striker but
saki's like the striker yeah you know
what i'm saying like if the were you
nervous for this one and you also again
not at all you're an underdog i i had
like just your normal competition nerves
but this one was also a bit personal in
a way like you know at the weigh-ins
like i remember he was like you're a
little boy you're scared like and i was
like oh my gosh like
you had no respect you know what i mean
just like there was no respect so like
as soon as it was made personal then i
was like okay well then
like
fights on
you i mean like such a savage dude yeah
so like i used to love watching him
fight yeah you know actually we were
scheduled to fight before and then he
had his knee injury yep and i saw him at
the pi and i was like hey man when you
when you heal up
uh
i want to fight you like i don't want to
wait in line like i will be your next
fight when you heal and what do you say
he's like okay he's like but we stood up
man and man he's like okay but standing
bang and i was like standing bang and i
shook his hand like jesus that's like i
was confident that you know i wanted to
match my striking up with his and so
many people were telling take him down
and i was like when have you ever seen
me shoot a takedown in my in my career
ever i think that's why the ufc wanted
this fight too because they knew you
were going to stand and bang
which is adopted i mean a tough day in
the office to stand and ban bang with
this guy especially with his credentials
you know yeah and i knew it see i'm like
a lot more light on my feet and moving
around like i know what's in front of
you
you look completely different than when
you fought paul craft yeah yeah
could you get you'd be a little more on
your ex's nose here yeah make a mistake
you won one small mistake a hand or foot
or anything and it's over oh world-class
spider-man especially world-class
fighter that if he knows you're going to
stand with them he's as relaxed as they
get yeah i mean he's beat some of the
very best ever do it yeah the kick was
pretty filthy his flexibility in the
hips is insane mm-hmm i mean his kick
power
just
oh he is who he is for a reason you know
what i mean
you have bad intentions on those punches
right
we're out of almost a minute into the
first round i mean you guys are
you're not feeling each other out
and we're just trying to find where the
range
yeah you both try to figure out the
range first like whoever lands
one of them stung me
did you felt this power yeah
anything that you've
felt before
did you feel the
the legendary saki power
i mean like it it
it hurt but i don't think that it landed
enough for me like landed clean enough
for me to really feel like what's what
he's got you know
oh [ __ ]
those leg kicks were pretty vicious that
he was going for it too yeah absolutely
just time that perfect yeah and that has
to be a great feather in your cat though
man yeah a win over that guy
like that's it
no it was more like it was kind of like
a like that reaction you know is more
like
it's
just
again like just like disrespect you know
or just like you know i get that it's
fighting and that like everybody does
what they do to
hype themselves up or whatever but like
you know nothing about me like and then
dude honestly too like i've never gotten
so much hate mail in my life like
turkish fans like you come to turkey i'm
kill you yeah it was really bad and i
still get croatian yeah it was really
really bad and so like
you know it was kind of just like
another just like to shake off all the
all the bad [ __ ] man like just
shake it off when you fight those
legends like you know they have these
insane fan bases where people came up
with them while you know they're these
world-class
fighters and then they get to ufc it's
just a different animal you know i think
for me the the one good thing when i
fought crow cop is he was a legend and i
had so much respect for him
but
i was just so young and inexperienced i
was like i'm gonna smoke this old man
that's like no young stopper this dude
yeah and it was the fight of love it was
a war it was a goddamn war but you
passed that in flying colors knocked him
out
uh there seems to be a common theme with
you in your your career where if you
feel disrespected it's uh it's an issue
do you think it's your own thing do you
think do you do you think it's like kind
of uh
something
you kind of
it's kind of an inner struggle you know
what i'm saying it's the fight game
right yeah it's it's it's the fight game
but like i guess in a way i just kind of
think like
like
if i didn't do anything or say anything
first then what have i done
like then what have i done to
have you like feel like you can just
approach me in this manner or say what
you want to say or you know what i mean
call me a little boy or whatever it is
that you're like
i don't get it yeah you know what i mean
i'm not the guy out here popping off and
talking [ __ ] or saying yeah i'm better
than this guy like i don't mention
another fighter yeah it's not in your
nature i think these guys especially
when they come to the ufc they feel like
they have to do it yeah maybe because
the conor mcgregor effect a little bit
which also if i'm a fighter and i'm i'm
going to fight you down the road and we
can talk about your next fight what you
want to do but and i watch this i'm not
going to disrespect you you know what
i'm saying i'm like well that's what he
gets up for that should be cool calm
collected well it's it's
let's talk about a little bit like just
of the growth and like
kind of the journey that i'm on right i
told you like i want to be a better
person like just part of my life so
it's a lot of that has gone away
the like if you disrespect me like i
don't even really think about it anymore
you know what i mean i don't really need
to feel like carl robertson didn't
disrespect me
you know at least
you know nothing that i think like i
don't know nothing that he did was
disrespectful and still it was like you
know a different type of fight so i do i
think if anything you should get the
disrespect from the odds makers again
you're an underdog in this fight as well
all three fights we've watched you're an
underdog you beat all three of them cool
like that's the disrespect you know the
the odds makers yeah let me be the
underdog
you know let me be the underdog
yeah it seems to be working out for you
yeah but i think it's good that you
don't have to
harness that you know that disrespect to
you know get the job done as you get
older you know and get more experience
yeah my fuel my fuel is a bit different
differently yeah yeah good for you man
shaved head here yeah man there's the
reason behind that age like just the top
of my head doesn't want to sprout any
more hair so fair enough yeah started
going with the shaved
because i don't want to get like a hair
transplant or anything
no that's always weird or like if you do
the lebron james where do they spray
paint yeah i don't want to do it you
know
because you have to maintain but also
you look pretty sweet with a [ __ ] black
guys look way better with shaved heads
than white guys
this is actually my first time watching
the fight oh really yeah i've only ever
seen like what was on on the computer
you look pretty shredded here how much
you weigh here you look good
i came back in fight day 2 25. you look
pretty jacked here dude yeah like for
that paul craig fight you looked a
little more smoother
uh this one you're definitely a little
more bulkier
you got a lower base here you're not
moving as much take down worry about the
take down here too no not so much the
base is very you're very like
you know level i like to mix it up yep
give them something to worry about yeah
i like to mix it up and again it's
martial arts right so like i do think
like when i'm when i'm training like how
can i
do things differently you know what i
mean or like yeah
you know maybe that's why they haven't
put me in the video game yet
son of a [ __ ]
i want to put you in the video game
i think robertson is the hardest hitter
i've ever rather he is swinging for the
fences yeah that's the other thing just
these three fights in a fight there's a
common theme too there's no feeling out
period with you you're not a slow
starter you know like cerrone's a slow
starter yeah jds a little bit of a slow
starter jon jones can be considered a
slow starter you are not sir
you're far from it
like once that bell rings you're you're
ready to go here why wait man
like we've been waiting you know eight
weeks yeah that's fair [ __ ] wait we are
a minute thirty into the first round you
boys are not i mean there's nobody like
he's fast robertson's throw in man yeah
yeah he's a beast and he had krauss in
his corner right so like that's
something that i was also thinking about
like
you know i'm like damn krause is like a
technician of a coach in my opinion and
like you know here i am going against a
guy who's fast powerful you know same
record like you know it was
there was a lot of a lot of motivation
behind
a lot behind this one was in vegas yeah
the apex
yeah man again rightfully so he's
throwing yeah this dude has bad
intentions
i'm sure you like fighting at the apex
right it's easy for you yeah i enjoy it
it's a home game for you yeah
and it just it feels more
like martial arts you know like like the
arena is big and there's a lot of people
in the you know like
it's intense yeah this it feels like
almost like a
kumate type of style you know like it's
pretty quiet and there's only a couple
hundred people in there
yeah i'm not really sure
yeah
you're a little thicker though
here you're just still trying to feel it
out laying something well like because
he had hit me early on i knew like he's
got power right
so i knew that i had like at this point
i was already just settled in for three
rounds
gotcha as soon as i felt in punch i was
i settled in for three rounds
and i think that's where the knockout
comes to it it's always tough to get
knockout when you're searching for it
like they can almost smell it like what
you're going for yeah the knockouts
happen i mean you tell me the knockouts
happen when you're you you know just
you're not thinking about it you're just
doing what you were coached to do
yeah it's almost like a reactive thing
yeah you guys are sitting in the pocket
man
he went for a takedown but not very
successful
but he's also calmed down too because
you've been landing obviously a lot more
as well again all your fights man if you
you know it's all in hindsight but look
at them if you're a betting man you're
like oh
cleo's gonna knock the guy out like you
can just sense it you know
like everything's so close to a
finish i don't like how he's reaching
out like that his coach can't like that
i think he's confused i don't think he
really knows what to do here you know
yeah like he hasn't thrown a punch and
we're at 40 seconds in the first round
now left he hasn't really thrown a punch
in over a minute he's trying to feel it
out i think i think he's trying to kind
of download datum like all right
nothing's landing the takedown didn't
work
you keep cutting him off
the jab's there
i hate how he's pawn that would drive me
nuts about his coach oof
little muay thai catch kick throw a
punch yeah you think you'd learn too
those kicks is getting lit the [ __ ] up
here's the other thing if i'm watching
this a don't don't disrespect you
because you get knocked out b
i would be careful with my light kicks
you know what i'm saying like any guy
that's throwing a light kick at you you
counter and beat the [ __ ] out of that
landed
a little double drop cross yeah
this one makes out of the first round
yeah but it's like very short into the
second round
yeah he's i'm sure
i'd love to hear his coaching between
the rounds there because he seems pretty
um confused
nothing was really working for him well
if i was this coach like no more light
cakes dude he's counter every single
time he's waiting on the leg kick they
definitely wanted him to get like to
take the cage more like take the center
more yeah because he's on his back foot
the entire
second one of the first round he's been
like oh my god
yeah that right hook just my favorite
part of the fight is the
heel hook escape it's a body kick
that was sick that was sick
just like really quick and then boom
that's the vanderlaan you man
yeah he's just
covering for their life there
yeah so
yeah man i think it's just uh that was a
violent one yeah yeah is it weird to see
yourself at like that in that mode no
no you like it it's kind of cool in a
way it's cool you know like it's it's
it's pretty cool it'd be cool when you
have kids yeah and they watch it yeah i
think about that all the time that's
great i think it's just now i think
moving forward is just a continuation of
everything i've been doing and just keep
trying to progress as as a fighter man
as a person before we get you out of
here and what would if you're the if
you're dana white what's next for you
what would be in a perfect world what do
you get where when
i have no idea if if if i'm
if i'm myself and not dana white
and what i'd want is
um
i don't mind being the underdog so like
i'm i'm you know i'd i'd like to at
least
a five-rounder
you wanna you wanna like
yeah like a five-round main event you
know what i mean
for that i don't really it's not like
that's what i want next but like i think
that that's kind of the next step for me
as far as
you know like
what i'm willing to prepare myself for
you know because
it's all about growth and i think to
train for a five-round fight
requires a lot of growth it's gonna push
it to a different level for sure yeah so
i can do like another you know another
three-round fight but i'd say like a
five round would be somewhere like
a cool way to close out the year i agree
i hope it happens man i think it well
thank you that kid uh who's that monster
he's not here but out hill
he's a tough character
no no comment i don't really comment on
another fight yeah i'm saying as far as
the face unless i fought them already
like yeah i'm saying that as far as a
fan goes would be a fun matchup
like yeah sure whatever
you don't care well whatever it is i
think you're gonna get a big fight man i
appreciate you doing this that's fun
thanks a little trip down memory lane
even though that one just happened
right after this you gave that fire ass
from the heart interview as well so uh
god
great love it thank you man thank you
[Music]
a little bit of work don't scare us i
get up i go hard like i'm george harris
make plays break lanes push weight break
chains go hard kick ass take names